they were in harlem shooting
the scenes and like the neighbors had
their windows open in the projects and
you could just hear all these women
saying i love you denzel
have you ever crashed a set
i've crashed a lot of film sets that
used to be my my mo that was the thing
that i did
very early on in my career i haven't
done that in a long time i usually get
invited now to set
um
there was uh
there was one particular time that i
want to share about
where uh this was again or very early in
my career when i was just starting i was
very green and business and i just
wanted to make things happen uh so what
i would do is look at the
there are websites where
uh you could find where a film is
shooting the street the days they're
shooting uh
maybe the project they'll make up a
different name for it
and they'll change the name of the
actors that are in it or they'll just
have their character name
um just to be discreet
but i would do a ton of research and
figure it out and just pop up you know
just pop up and there was someone i
wanted to work with or get in front of i
had like a plan
of how i wanted to talk to him what i
wanted to say
i'd say that a lot of the times it did
work it was successful there was this
time where um a friend of mine that
lived in staten island uh she was she
was not in the business but she was in
entertainment and loved the arts and she
knew that i would crash film sets and
this friend of mine in staten island
she went on
to
uh tell me like hey they're shooting
this movie you know in staten island and
james is writing and
directing it um and it must have been
like
10 11 o'clock at night um and i called
my ex-business partner i said
i found out this information and he's
like i'm available i said let's go
so we drove
from long island to
um staten island uh over the verrazado
bridge we got to the film set and it
wasn't a huge set but it was a decent
size set and
we um we just kind of blended in and
just waited for them to rap we were just
being respectful and back then james was
always known for wearing a suit you know
and ty when he directed it was funny
that was his thing um so at the end when
they rap we approached james and i
introduced myself and told him how much
we you know loved his work and you know
the stuff they'd written before and then
we went to build a relationship with him
and uh if we could get his contact
information and he shared his phone
number and email which was really
freaking cool
and then what happened later on is that
i had produced a short that we took to
the short film corner at the cannes film
festival
and we had told james that we were going
and he said hey guys well you should
meet with my producing partner this guy
named sebastian
and sebastian works with him a lot
and um
he said that sebastian had like three
films in competition which it's hard to
get one filming competition but
sebastian had three uh sebastian is
french um so we met with sebastian at
some fancy hotel in can i don't remember
the name of it but i remember like it
was yesterday it was um
it was just a great highlight of my
career just remembering it like it was
bright it was a beautiful hotel
and sebastian is telling us about his
movies and then working with james and
telling us about some little movie they
did
uh
michael bay put his name on it and um
universal will get behind it because of
michael bay and ethan hawk is in it um
and then it's a little movie they'll see
how it does and um
at the end of the whole thing he said
that uh well there's an after party for
one of my films uh tonight you know
here's two tickets love for you two to
come and they were like these golden
tickets like i imagine like imagine
these like old tickets from the 1600s or
whatever 1700s and they were like golden
tickets and had the name of the venue
and all these things and
this was kind of balls ballsy of me to
do but
at the time we had this intern named
cassandra and she spoke every language
under the sun and she came out there
with us and it's very interesting
because when we were planning to go to
can we we're looking where to stay and
she's like you know we never really knew
her deal um
um but she said yeah you know um well
since you guys are gonna go to can you
know um i have a house uh out there and
we're like wait you have a house in can
you know it's right outside of canyon
it's in uh ducat which is a very fancy
area
um
and uh she ended up living in like a
manson which is ridiculous
um so we stayed with our intern
in her you know manson um i mean her
family owns it so it's not really her
house but
she has a boat and all these things and
we learned all these things about
cassandra and she took very good care of
us and drove us to all of our meetings
and things he can
so i asked sebastian and said listen i
know you have two you're probably
limited what you can give but cassandra
is here with us you know she's a really
good person she's kind and she's
appropriate and um we are staying with
her and i don't want her to just be at
home when we're at this thing or drop us
off and is there any way you can spare
an extra ticket and
he looked at me
and then
he took the phone made a phone call um
and
i used to speak fluent friends i don't
speak fluent friends but he spoke
something in france hung up the phone
and he went back in his pocket and gave
us a third ticket
so cassandra was able to attend with us
and it was my first you know time at can
this time around and
um it was everybody that was an a-lister
with this was it this thing
l-f-m-a-o i don't know how you say you
know they were there i think the smurfs
was coming out the producer of the
smurfs and the venue was like this
castle on a mountain and there was a
long line to get into this thing with
our golden tickets we skipped the line
walked straight in and it was one of the
best nights that i had in cannes you
know and i've been to can that was my
first time they can um i'd gone one
other time after but um
yeah it was amazing and sebastian was a
pipeline you know for us
and then we ended up selling that short
film to uh sorts international until
this day i still get a residual check
every like six months to a year you know
it's not a lot of money but a few
hundred dollars we've we've
made decent money on that short um we so
it was sold worldwide
and um
about a year later you know
nba finals that film that little movie
that sebastian and james demonica were
talking about was called the purge and
it changed james's life
and i called up james i'm like james you
know like i want to rock with you like
how can i get involved with you and do
more and he's like listen rampant
there's not much i can do i'm a writer
director but you know if you ever need
any support call my agent and i
developed a relationship there and um
um the assistant this guy named michael
um had he was a great you know assistant
he now is an agent at the verve town
agency and we've become you know friends
and anytime i need something at verve i
could go to him you know
and um that all started because i took
the risk to
you know go out you know to uh you know
staten island to meet this guy so that's
probably the most successful you know
story
you know in terms of that and um
uh
there's been many other times where i've
just popped up on sets and it hasn't
worked
i was an extra on american gangster and
um
that was when i first started acting and
it was the first movie i big movie i did
extra work on and it was just amazing to
see ridley scott work and
all the talent like just everybody was
in that movie idris elba and denzel and
russell and t.i it was an incredible
experience um
and the day that i was there there was
no way there was an opportunity for me
to get in front of denzel and the
reality of it is that
everybody wants to talk to denzel i just
remember when they were in harlem
shooting the scenes and like the
neighbors had their windows open in the
projects and you could just hear all
these women saying i love you denzel
it was just so classic it was like oh my
god i felt like i was in training day
watching that scene where you know he's
in the projects and everybody in the
hood is like a blood gang member that's
what it felt like you know
and it was just wow just being there and
um and everybody just like went to go
ask for an autograph or take a picture
and that wasn't my goal or intention and
i wanted to speak to him
i'll tell you why in a second um so i
said let me go talk to ridley scott
so i wanted to release scott there
weren't as many people lined up for him
you know i mean there were people lined
up for him but not compared to denzel um
and you know i just complimented him on
his work what he's done
very familiar with all his work and his
accomplishments and not that he cares it
i'm you know me the extras complimenting
him you know he probably doesn't care
but you know i just was genuine with it
and i was very ballsy with what i said i
said listen i want to work with you you
know how can that and this is when i was
you know just acting i wasn't really
thinking about producing as much you
know i
just thought about it a little bit but
i was just telling him that and i
i guess inappropriate to tell him that
you know and um
uh what happened next was that i'd asked
him for his phone number i said listen i
want to give you a call let's sit down
take you to lunch and you know and i
doesn't quite work that way um and his
first a.d was there in time to save him
and get him out
and he said no contact me and that
meeting with ridley scott never happened
you know
what i ended up doing again which was
really ballsy uh this is before wme was
formed there was william morris agency
and endeavour i called his office and i
said
met ridley you know we hit it off well
and uh i want to work with him you know
so uh how do we get started
something along like that i got the
assistant and i guess the assistant knew
you know like this is not gonna work and
you know and um i'd send my headset and
resume and my black and white that i
just got made and um
and uh i followed up and said you know
after i submitted and checked in i'm
like all right i'm ready to work with
ridley and
um and the guy at the time he just said
no it's not going to work and i realized
i wasn't going to get through this is
not going to work so
i changed my strategy and i said hey you
know you are going to be an agent one
day
you know what i'm trying to do
let's build a relationship and that's
what happened me and the assistant
developed the relationship i came out to
la and then we went to some sushi
restaurant that people used to love
going to i can't remember the name of it
but we had like this really nice dinner
it was somewhere in west hollywood and i
developed a relationship with this guy
that was on his way to becoming a talent
agent unfortunately um he got caught up
it spiraled down for him and he had to
leave the industry so it didn't quite
manifest into that but um i i believe i
accomplished my goal and
uh and uh it was a good friendship that
uh me and this gentleman had created um
and now back to denzel
um i did want to get in front of denzel
the reason was that i heard he was
getting ready to direct
and i wanted to work with him he was on
his way to do this movie called the
great debaters you know and i wanted an
opportunity to at least audition and you
know and be in the film uh
so
uh there was a day that i was not
scheduled to be on set and i found out
where they were going to be shooting i
crashed the set and i blended in and um
i there's a smart way to do it where
you know people are not going to kick
you off set you know that's what i
figured just reading the temperature of
the set and the body language and um
you're not doing anything inappropriate
so i just kind of just like walked
around and
and then at some point denzel walked out
out of this
restaurant or whatever he was completely
by himself
oh my god this is my moment you know so
i took that moment went up to him i said
denzel he turned around
and um i introduced myself i spoke with
him and then someone turned around
because there's always eyes on him he's
a-list talent someone realized that wait
a second i'm not supposed to be there
i'm speaking to him
no no no no
and um they ran over and
interrupted you know and said that he
had to go and then i had to leave you
know and um there was someone else that
i got to know on set there and uh he
came up to me and he said listen and
what you did was like it's not
appropriate and you know it's probably
good if you leave and um
and he's like you don't
i had the option not that i had the
option to leave or not to leave but um
i just thought like what's the highest
good here you know um i can stay and try
to do this again um but now you know it
kind of squandered my plans
so
i
didn't think it would be smart if i did
stay and try to get in front of him
again because
of just the way the interaction went so
i ultimately decided just to leave you
know um but um it's funny because i
ended up developing a really good
relationship with denzel whitaker you
know who got the role that i wanted and
we actually worked on this project with
um
david oyelowo
two years ago
and it kind of just came back full
circle you know like denzel whitaker and
i have become like the dearest of
friends and you know we're homies um
but even though it didn't work out i'm
glad that i took that shot because i
live in a place of um
i don't want to be in a coulda woulda
sort of you know i know that i i tried
and i'm happy with what i at least did i
know that um it just didn't work out it
wasn't it wasn't in i guess my best for
it to work out or the project's best
and um i'm happy that
denzel whittaker took that role because
after that he became who he is now
i like your stories that what have you
thought of of working with the
screenwriter like if you had one about
just the whole thing you talked about
with cassandra you hear you have this
intern she speaks all these languages
you're thinking great we've got these
two golden tickets to khan and then you
find out she's got this family man i
mean that that's like its own movie
right there
yeah you know you can't make it up
driving around two eager producers like
in france i don't know
so
there's no way i've driven around in
france because the vespas like the way
to drive the vessels i feel like i would
have hit one of these guys and the car
we rented was stixxif and granted i know
how to drive stakes if but i'm not great
at it and we're up these hills where if
you went a little bit too far right
you'll fall over the cliff with no
barrier i was extremely terrified to
drive in italy the way that they drive
and
i'm not italy i'm sorry um
france we went to italy after we flew
into milan got the car from milan and
drove to you know can um cop foray and
uh so
there's no way i would have done that i
don't feel comfortable driving out there
the way that they drive especially a
stixxif
vehicle on show
so yeah cassandra was so clutch and so
meaningful to that trip that we had my
first time at camp